und mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt mein
kollege bild reporter mark pittelkau er
hat die beiden siegfried und roy
jahrzehntelange begleitet mag was weiß
man genaueres wo könnte sich neu
angesteckt haben und wie wurde er
behandelt die aussage siegfried ist ja
die dass sowohl an bei einem gärtner hat
sich ja oft draußen aufgehalten und hat
natürlich seinen mitarbeitern und
angestellten ist immer zur hand gegangen
das ist möglicherweise so gekommen ist
weil sie tritt selbst und auch seine
pfleger sind ja negativ getestet worden
es heißt es wäre ein gärtner gewesen
aber so richtig lässt sich das natürlich
nicht mehr herausfinden wo bei war ja
kaum das haus verlassen hat und
eigentlich immer nur bei seinen tieren
war
man weiß es nicht und er wusste es am
ende wohl auch selbst nicht mehr du
kanntest und kennst beide sehr sehr
lange wann hast du roi zum letzten mal
gesprochen
ich habe neu getroffen 0 zuletzt das war
im dezember 2018 daran wir in das leben
seines achtzigsten geburtstag gefeiert
hannover ist nach wie vor mit sigrid und
war mit sehr eng befreundet die beiden
waren ehrengäste als wir im wiener hotel
ein großes dinner gemacht haben und am
nächsten tag waren wir dann bei 79 noch
zum kaffeetrinken zum adventskaffee
eingeladen und haben dort ein paar nette
stunden verbracht eistorte und
cappuccino
die beiden waren immer sehr
gastfreundlich und es war wirklich immer
ein erlebnis dort zu gast sein zu dürfen
und roy war ein bisschen nein er war gut
drauf aber er hat nicht viel gesprochen
er hat eigentlich siegfried meistens das
reden über lassen weil ja nicht mehr so
gut sprechen konnte
da musste sich sehr konzentrieren durch
seine schlaganfälle tierarten zählen das
sprechen schwer und man musste sehr
genau hinhören und sich konzentrieren
wenn man wirklich verstehen wollte was
er sagte und das war an diesem
nachmittag so aber ich weiß noch genau
wie ich mich dann am ende von ihm
verabschiedet habe und mich noch einmal
gedacht habe was ich immer gemacht habe
für diese freundschaft die sich schon
wirklich in 25 jahren entwickelt hat
und da hat er mir zum ende auch einen
kleinen engel aus glas geschenkt und hat
gesagt
dieser engel soll auf dich aufpassen und
dich beschützen und ich kann in dieser
stunde nur sagen dass ich hoffe dass wir
jetzt auch darum ein engel hat der auf
ihn aufpasst und ja und wir werden für
immer ein gesenkter und unnahbare
erinnerung behalten ja du kanntest du
auch privat ein großer einschnitt in roy
horns leben war 2003 das gerade
angesprochen
der unfall als er von seinem lieblings
tiger auf der bühne angegriffen wurde
wie hat er das damals verkraftet aber
zunächst lager ja ein koma lange wochen
und monate und man hat ja gesagt der
wird nie wieder aufstehen damit die
bilder sprechen und wird für immer ein
pflegefall sein breu ist aber ein
gemeinden sehr starken willen hat und er
hat natürlich es geschafft tatsächlich
wieder zu genesen er ist halbwegs
gelähmt geblieben
es war für ihn schrecklich diese zeit
als er wach wurde und gemerkt hat er
kann sich nicht mehr richtig bewegen hat
seine motorik verloren er hat seine
sprache teilweise verloren seiner
verständlichkeit aber im besten sinne
auch ein eitler mensch der natürlich
sich sehr gefallen hat er war ein sehr
gut aussehender mann er war nach dieser
tiger nach diesem tiger unfall auch
äußerlich sehr verändert ich glaube es
hat ihm schwer zu schaffen gemacht dass
er nicht mehr der alte war ich habe
immer gesagt für mich war das eigentlich
die größten tragödien die ich jemals
erlebt habe wenn man den mann getarnt
hat vorher vitaler war reagiert er war
das ist dann wirklich da nur noch so ein
häufchen elend am anfang stehen dann im
rollstuhl
das musste ihn sehr schwer sagt gewesen
sein er hat es aber immer mit sich
selbst ausgemacht muss ich sagen er nie
gejammert er nie sich beklagt oder
irgendjemand gesagt die es in ihm
aussieht war er unglaublich starker
mensch wahr er hat tief im innern hat er
eine stärke gehabt die auch aus seiner
religiosität hervorging war sehr
religiös und ich glaube dass glaube an
gott und natürlich auch die tiefe
freundschaft zu siegfried haben ihm den
lebensmut zurück gegeben dass er auch
ohne die schont und mitunter diesen
wirklich bedingungen die man nicht hätte
erahnen können woher weiter leben konnte
und auch glücklich weiter leben konnte
ich hoffe bis zum schlusstag auf vielen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
ganz las vegas ist in trauer
dort lebten siegfried und leben
siegfried und roy und dort gab es ihre
bomben show im hotel mirage